Abortion until week 14,
although it is possible
week 22 if there is a risk to the mother
or the fetus has an anomaly.
Is Spain free?
Yes, it's free,
but normally
you're going to find a lot of Cola in social security
and most of
produce in private clinics.
The cost of this will be between 300 to €600.
There are certain provinces in Spain
in which
there is no Voluntary Termination of Pregnancy Center,
but probably
in the neighboring provinces there are,
so you can travel by bus
or by train to get to your Center.
If you are of legal age
you won't have any kind of problem,
but if you are between the ages of 16 and 18,
so you will need permission from your parents.
and if you want to terminate 1 pregnancy,
how do we do it?
First things first
is to request 1 appointment
in your Voluntary Pregnancy Intervention Center
of your autonomous community
or your province.
How do you find these centers?
Very easy,
you can ask your doctor,
you can go to 1 Family Planning Center
or in the association of clinics
accredited for termination of pregnancy
who have 1 list of all the centers in Spain.
When you arrive at the Center,
in the same act
all steps will be solved
to be followed.
In 1 closed envelope
will give you all the information about help
and after that
you will have to wait at least 3 days
in order to submit you to the voucher.
When the day comes,
what will the procedure be like?
First you have to come on an empty stomach,
you have to go with your ID card
with 1 previous ultrasound
and with 1 previous blood test.
Also when you arrive
you will be given some papers to fill in,
will do another ultrasound
to confirm the week of pregnancy
and see how the uterus is
and another new blood test will also be made for you.
In case you are nervous.
You will also be given psychological support
for you to do what you do
do it because you choose it
and not because you have pressure or feel guilty.
After this
will be switched to termination of pregnancy,
either surgically orly
and after 1 time of supervision you will be discharged.
In Spain,
fortunately it is free,
is free and secure
and no one is forcing you to do something you don't want to do.
So USE your rights
and if at any time you want to be a Mother,
be it,
but it doesn't have to be now